what's going on everybody so yesterday
brie Larson sent out a tweet to
Entertainment Weekly that said hey at
the UW I'm bored want to break to
internet tomorrow Entertainment Weekly
then replied yes meet us here at noon
Eastern Time we've got something
marvelous in mind in which brie Larson
responded with it's a date so twelve
o'clock comes and Entertainment Weekly
tweets out the latest issue of their
magazine with Captain Marvel smack dab
right on the middle of the cover you can
see it right here it looks awesome it
looks like Captain Marvel staring right
into your eyes and the tweet reads the
Futurist female here's your exclusive
first look at brie Larson as Captain
Marvel the galaxy's newest and most
powerful star it's interesting that they
say the most powerful in the tweet and
on the cover you can see it on the right
there it says the future is female your
very first look at the galaxy's newest
and most powerful star they're really
drilling this end they've said before
that Captain Marvel will be insanely
powerful and it looks like nothing has
changed and the Avengers are going to
need it they got their butts kicked by
Thanos so it would make sense that
Captain Marvel comes in more powerful
than the current Avengers her outfit
looks awesome we've seen it before but
never with this much detail it looks
great and I love that they're sticking
true to the uniform that she has in the
comics you could see that her hands are
essentially on fire that's because she
has the ability to absorb energy and
basically shoot them out of her hands as
laser beams yeah pretty cool and again
the outfit looks amazing sticking true
to the comic book look brie Larson looks
amazing so let's dive a little bit into
the sneak peek that aww gave us on their
website I'll put the link down in the
description below so this article is
called brie Larson takes flight as
Captain Marvel on this week's CW cover
and right below that there is a video
that Entertainment Weekly put together
in which they show this photo now the
cover photo of the magazine looks
amazing but it's the cover photo of a
magazine they always make it look a
little
bit better right they enhance it a
little bit but this photo right here is
a more truer photo with less done to it
and the uniform still looks amazing and
brie Larson looks amazing playing
Captain Marvel I think they did a really
good job at casting her for this I think
a lot of people were worried but I think
she's going to do an amazing job I think
she looks great here as Captain Marvel
so they do this little teaser video they
ask where she's been during all the MCU
events that have taken place and they
give a little bit of a history and
origin of Captain Marvel if you've seen
the video that I did on Captain Marvel
maybe a month or so ago you pretty much
know all this and if you haven't I'll
put it in the link above and I'll also
put it at the end of my video so the
article goes on to talk about how
Captain Marvel is going to be the first
female solo superhero movie for the MCU
and in this article it's the first time
that we actually hear and learn about
the character Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers here's what brie Larson had to
say in the interview about her character
she can't help but to be herself she can
be aggressive and she can have a temper
and she can be a little invasive and
in-your-face
she's also quick to jump to things which
makes her amazing in battle because
she's the first one out there and
doesn't always wait for orders but the
not waiting for orders is to some a
character flaw DW goes on to say that
she's a hero who's trying to figure out
how to reconcile her alien abilities
with her more human flaws here's
something that is really interesting
though aw goes on to say that when the
movie begins Carol already has her
powers she's left her earthly life
behind to join an elite Kree military
team called Star Force who is led by
Jude Law's and Nick mattock commander so
they're going to start the movie off
with her already having her powers now I
know they're going to tell us in the
movie at some point how she got them but
when it starts she will already have
them and she won't be on earth now they
do go on to say that she will find
herself on earth again with new
questions about her past they also
mentioned that she's got a formidable
enemy in the form of the
the notorious Marvel baddies made all
the more dangerous by their
shape-shifting abilities and also when
she gets back to earth it'll be in the
mid-90s this is before Steve Rogers was
defrosted it was before Tony Stark built
his first suit and that's why we're
going to see a young Nick Fury with two
eyes and according to this article he's
still going to be a desk jockey so he's
definitely not the director of shield at
this point this lets Carol Danvers carve
out her own unique space in the MCU they
then give us a part of the interview
they had with Anna Bowden who is the MC
use first female director directing
Captain Marvel this is what she had to
say this is not a superhero who's
perfect or otherworldly or has some
godlike connection but what makes her
special is just how human she is she's
funny but doesn't always tell good jokes
and she can be a headstrong and reckless
and doesn't always make the perfect
decisions for herself but at her core
she has so much heart and so much
humanity and all of its messiness this
is the most detail that we've gotten on
Captain Marvel both the film and the
character DW said that they will be
rolling out all kinds of details on the
film over the next few days including
exclusive photos details from their set
visit and in depth interviews with the
cast and crew so if you're new to my
channel make sure you subscribe but the
notifications turned on I will be
covering it all as soon as it comes out
let me know what you think of this
exclusive aw look at Captain Marvel as
well as what they've said and interviews
about the character and my giveaway
still continues I'm giving away a few
copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray if you'd like to enter all I
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero and as I mentioned before here
is the video on Captain Marvel's origin
and powers thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]